king philippe is the first belgian
monarch to express regret for his
country's past in the democratic
republic of congo
but his speech to the congolese
parliament in the capital kinshasa
stopped short of apologizing for the
violence and exploitation of belgium's
75-year colonial rule
it led to violent acts and humiliations
on the occasion of my first trip to
congo right here in front of the
congolese people and those who still
suffer today i wish to reaffirm my
deepest regrets for those wounds of the
past
king philippe and his wife queen matild
are on a six-day visit the monarch and
congolese president felix chisiketti
have spoken about cooperation and
development
they haven't mentioned the role of king
philippe's great-grandfather's brother
belgian king leopold ii
he turned congo into his personal
fiefdom in 1885
he made a fortune from rubber
which congolese were forced to harvest
from the forests their hands were cut
off if they didn't collect enough for
their rulers
up to 10 million people died it was the
black lives matter movement two years
ago that prompted activists to deface
statues of king leopold in belgium
some of the statues were removed and
king philippe expressed regret for the
first time
[Applause]
two years later he's visiting democratic
republic of congo for the first time
he brought back a mask one of thousands
of artifacts looted by the colonialists
he said it's on a permanent loan from a
belgian museum
for some congolese it falls far short of
making up for the past so the atrocity
of the red rubber the whipping the
repetitive humiliation suffered by our
ancestor our funding fathers and mothers
should not
become a case that goes unnoticed
because they refuse to formally
apologize
for president chisiketi it brings some
international credibility he took office
two and a half years ago after elections
that leaked documents appeared to show
were rigged belgium's prime minister
who's also on the visit was critical at
the time
relations have since improved
i believe that for the democratic
republic of congo and i have always said
this the gateway to europe i am talking
about diplomatic and political europe
business europe is belgium
belgium's rule in congo was one of the
bloodiest chapters of european
colonialism and one of its most
profitable with vast amounts of wealth
looted
but belgium has been among the slowest
of european powers to even start to
acknowledge the past
malcolm webb al jazeera